okay china has enough vacant property
right now according to a report
to house over 90 million people
or the entire population of germany
larger than the population of france uh
according to the financial times this
entire discussion has come up because of
evergrand something we've been talking
about for the last couple of months in
relation to tether and the commercial
paper that tether might own or might not
own in chinese companies
and the last time we spoke about
evergrand was on episode 1280
back on september 9th 11 days later on
monday september 20th the dow dropped
this was this monday as much as 971
points due to the fallout and the fear
of contagion from evergrand
it wound up only closing down two
percent
but it felt a little panicky on monday
an article published on tuesday in the
financial times revealed some shocking
stats about china's real estate industry
uh capped off by
the approximate 40 billion collapse of
evergrand which could be much more you
know again china
is very opaque we don't know what's
going on over there who knows the scale
of the fraud or these bonds and the
collapse we'll find out over time or
maybe we'll never know according to the
article the financial times china's real
estate sector is quote so overbuilt that
it threatens to relinquish its
long-standing role as the prime driver
of chinese economic growth and instead
become a drag on it fascinating sound
familiar
we had our own crisis over real estate
when real estate bubbles get going it
captures the imagination of the public
these houses start flipping people start
buying and a mania quickly ensues and
looks like china is going through that
and uh
you know
let me play a a clip here what you're
going to see right now is um
the result of i think a lot of this
being overbuilt you're seeing 15
unfinished high-rise apartments in the
southwestern chinese city of
being demolished before ever being used
it's pretty amazing to watch 15 homes 15
giant buildings go down at once
especially when we're sitting here in
america i think we need seven million
more homes
and they're just knocking them down
there by blowing them up
this video almost
doesn't look real it looks like some cgi
of the day after or some crazy
uh dystopian you know meter hitting
earth
who knows what exactly is going on here
maybe there's something wrong with these
buildings
maybe they had foundation problems maybe
people are not moving to that area so
it's a it's hard to know when you see
these videos i always look at them with
a bit of a
questioning eye as to what's really
going on here but they're literally
blowing up housing according to the
article chinese real estate industry
accounts for 29
percent of the country's gross gdp
the 90 million number in the article
came from calculation by logan wright a
director at
rhodium group which is a firm that sells
independent research on china's
financial and political landscape here
is how wright calculated the number
because i always ask my team when we're
doing research on this you know the
journalists will write stuff people will
share stuff on twitter can we find where
the original information came from and
just maybe dig a little deeper as to
where this came from
and here's how they came up with their
calculation unsold housing inventory in
china is approximately three billion
square meters
three billion square meters can house 30
million families the average family size
in china is three people so three times
30 90 million people can be housed with
3 billion vacant square meters of real
estate and by the way a country with 90
million people would be the 16th largest
one in the world uh bearing in mind that
there are over 260 countries in the
world
they should sit right between vietnam
and the
democratic republic of the congo in
terms of population
and according to the article china's
property growth at all cost model might
be coming to an end quickly
uh leland miller the ceo of china beige
book a firm that sells research on china
to institutional investors had the
following quote the leadership in
beijing has been more worried about
chinese growth than anyone in the west
there is a recognition that the old
build build build playbook does not work
anymore and that is actually getting
dangerous the leadership now appears to
be thinking that it can't wait any
longer to change the growth model we are
all set for a roller coaster ride in
policy and economic growth i would not
be surprised if a decade from now
china's gdp growth was one or two
percent
so uh just to give you an idea and some
context around china uh they've been
growing their gdp year over year since
2000 to give some context on how rapidly
china's gdp has been growing from 2000
to 2009 china's gdp grew on average 10.4
percent per year u.s averages about 1.9
percent uh during that period and uh the
u.s average is way down by the us gdp
regressing by 2.5 percent from 2008 and
2009 during the peak of the housing
crisis so
from 2010 to 2019 china's gdp grew an
average of 7.6 per year
us average 2.3 growth in the same time
period according to macro trends so
during that time period from 2013 to
2018 china was responsible for 28 of the
worldwide gdp according to the
international monetary fund you know
them as the imf that 28 percent of
worldwide gdp growth was double the u.s
number obviously china's growing fast
the financial times article highlights
other major red flags in the chinese
real estate market
land sales by local governments in china
have collapsed forward 90 year-over-year
from september 2020 to september 2021
and according to the article land sales
generate about one-third of local
government revenues in china so now we
start talking about contagion you can
start to understand how this could all
come apart people were investing
investing investing and now maybe that
housing isn't as needed
and the basically the music stops
the revenues obviously when they sell
this land
help pay the principal and interest on
8.4 trillion dollars in debt issued by
several thousand local government
financing vehicles
uh these vehicles raise capital by
issuing selling bonds from which they
use the proceeds to fund infrastructure
projects like building real estate so
the music is stopping feels like a giant
house of cards but in china they can
just print more money they can do
whatever they want
they can bail people out and that
means this probably will not uh be a
lehman brothers type moment the
contagion that we saw here
because the ccb can just do whatever
they want it's one of the great aspects
of being an authoritarian government
they can wipe out debt
they can print more money and just
basically do whatever they want without
anybody's approval it's a
you know authoritarian country so
something to totally watch and keep an
eye on because this is going to have
impact on the u.s market
hey everybody i thought i would bring
christina
cassiopo i pronounced it correct i'm
hoping chris you got it yep all right
you're the founder of vanta uh people
have been hearing your ads on the pod
for the last year and i thought it'd be
fun to have you on and you to explain
why you created vanta and what sock 2 is
and why it's important people get it
right so let's start with what is sock 2
for people who are just realizing they
have to become sock 2 compliant
for sure so
sock 2 is at a high level it's sort of a
customer asking you to prove your
security now these audit firms that you
partner with
you prepare everything but you still
need to have an auditor so who gets the
order you or
the company that is engaging vanta yeah
absolutely so one part of what we do at
vanta is we've we've built a network of
audit firms and there's a couple dozen
we work with today so we're happy to to
broker introductions help companies kind
of choose what sort of auditor or firm
would be best for them and then the
other part of the pitch is you know that
auditor knows vanta understands and
trusts our data and so the audit will be
faster and cheaper if one of our network
firms are used all right fantastic well
thanks so much for coming on and telling
the audience why you should get your
sock too when you should get it and how
you should do it and you've been very
nice to our audience giving them a
thousand dollars off which is a really
significant and generous offer go to
vanta.com twist v-a-n-t-a.com
twist to get a thousand dollars off your
sock too thanks christina appreciate it
thank you so much cheers now